there's no doubt that the number one
adversary the united states has had for
a long time
is communist china the dominant
party in the planet earth they're also
trying to dominate the economy of the
world and on top of it a pandemic a
worldwide pandemic was it developed in a
chinese lab
god only knows why are so many americans
buying
80 percent more guns these are
organizations blm
intifada who are rioting all over major
cities portland seattle
milwaukee la washington dc burning
destroying people looked at and said i
don't have a way of protecting my family
and they went out and bought firearms
the day-to-day person couldn't handle
the truth
if we really knew what was really taking
place if there's not
a national security component that needs
to be kept secret there ought to be
transparency
interesting to say that there needs to
be more of that in washington
there needs to be more cooperation who's
going to be biden's biggest enemy i'm
looking at some of the things that he's
announced in his executive orders
and politically economically
and national security wise i don't see
bidens being particularly helpful to
what we need to be as a nation
my yesterday has an extensive resume
lieutenant colonel oliver north i think
he's the 66
former uh 66th president of the nra two
purple hearts three patents
17 best-selling books very very deep
experience military politics so with
that being said uh
lieutenant colonel oliver north thank
you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
good to be with you patrick so i got a
few topics i want to go through so i'm
just going to get right into the topics
and i'm curious to know what you're
going to be thinking about
so for me i'm a guy that lived in iran
10 years okay so 78 to 89
we left we go to germany two years
refugee camp then i come out here i go
in the military then later on i become a
business owner et cetera et cetera
so my history is somewhat tied to the
middle east
iran mother side communist that side
imperialist i
myself capitalist okay so put all those
uh
different background together when i
think about the current time
and i think about trump versus biden i'm
curious to know what you're going to say
to this
under a trump administration that we had
who were our top enemies during a trump
administration who were our top enemies
maybe
you're going to say china iran whatever
the list may be from you
but i'm also curious to know what you
think now under a
biden administration who our top enemies
are so trump administration
administration what would you say okay
there's no doubt that the number one
adversary the united states has had for
a long time is communist china
it's an authoritarian country they aim
to be
the dominant party in the planet earth
number two would be iran because
the uncertainty as to whether they're
going to use the nuclear weapons that
they're building and they are building
nuclear weapons
and the icbms that they're testing just
did one year what four or five days ago
the fact is communist china is helping
make that happen why
because it's to their advantage to have
us distracted by other things
besides what's going on in communist
china communist chinese
are today committing genocide against
the uigar people
and others they're committing the kinds
of threats to democracy that they
promised to abide by when the british
signed the treaty
giving hong kong their ultimate you know
catastrophe
number three they're building literally
military bastions all over the south
china sea by dredging up coral
and building runways and arming them
things that they said they'd never do
number four
they're threatening taiwan this is just
this past week we ended up with the u.s
navy
freedom of navigation exercise going
through the
straits of taiwan in which at least a
half dozen maybe as many as 10
different communist chinese aircraft
overflew that usa
the us destroyer that was going through
the straits
those kinds of things say a lot about
where they're heading
they're also trying to dominate the
economy of the world
their so-called belt and road initiative
which takes
basically most of sub-saharan africa is
dominated today by communist china yeah
i mean i've been out there i've seen
every every time you go to a major city
in sub-saharan africa
you're looking at communist chinese
engineers and you're looking here in the
united states of communist chinese
military intelligence people coming to
our colleges and university
to steal our intellectual property much
of it has to do with things like
weapons with whom we deal very closely
with israel
understandably the israelis are very
concerned i mean we've got an
impeachment trial going on as you and i
are speaking
where there's an impeachment trial going
on in washington dc
and at the same time one of america's
closest allies
maybe netanyahu is on trial in jerusalem
i mean we have never seen in my lifetime
i was born when fdr was president okay
we've never seen in our lifetime
anything like this and on top of it a
pandemic a worldwide pandemic
that was actually supported by what the
communist chinese refused to do
and that was tell everybody how
communicable this terrible disease is
it's now mutating in south africa
in the so-called uk version of it we
have no idea
whether the vaccines were developed in
such enormous rush
you know operational warp speed by
president trump we have no idea if these
things are going to protect us
from this new mutant variant of that
disease
was it developed in a chinese communist
lab god only knows
i don't know but i do know that they did
everything in their power to keep us
from finding out
how communicable it was how deadly it is
and the bottom line of it is
the communist chinese are behind all
that stuff and on top of that we've got
60 or 70
of these so-called confucius institutes
co-located on american college
university which are teaching
communist chinese ideology
and when you look at all of those things
the soft power the hard power the kinds
of military activities
there's no doubt coming in as china is
still the number one adversary
does the biden administration realize
that the only i know the call would be
hunter biden if you can get him on the
show he's probably making america's
foreign policy toward china
uh so so the reason why i asked this
from you is the following question
because
so whether it's trump or whether it's
biden enemy number one enemy is the same
china number two enemy in your eyes same
iran
where do you go from there do you go or
do you go russia do you go
you know turkey because i know turkey is
an ally but turkey's a little too
powerful in the middle east and they're
kind of bullying
guys that are bigger than him what do
you russia what do you put other people
below iran
well look i mean what we've got to do is
count on our nato allies to stand up
and one trump reimposed the sanctions
the pressure against the iranian regime
aimed not at creating a war aimed at
bringing the people of iran to the point
where they say look
we need a regime change here it doesn't
need to be revolutionary
we just need to vote out the theocracy
that's running the country
running iran into the dirt to continue
to maintain the
enormous expenditures that are required
to build nuclear weapons and the means
of delivering them
who's the number one target for iran
remember we are the great satan
but remember it's a lot closer to israel
and so israel has got to regard
themselves as the
most likely target if not their if not
the ultimate design
and what the united states needs to make
sure that we can do is
do the kinds of intellectual property
investigations and
research and development on the best
means of deterring that kind of attack
you know the our military doesn't exist
to fight wars
we need to be capable of fighting a war
and winning but our military exists
to deter adversaries from doing bad
things to us
attacking our country it's been
successful that throughout the entire
cold war the president i was blessed to
serve
ronald reagan understood that you know
peace through strength was one of his
mottos and the idea of
making sure that the bad guys are not
doing bad things how about the old
expression trust could verify that's
ronald reagan that's what every
president needs to be able to do
trump did it very forcefully there's no
doubt that
president trump said things in a way
that i would not say them and probably
you wouldn't say them but the fact is
if you look at the policies both
domestically and internationally with
trump
he got nato to stand up and start paying
her fair share he added countries to the
nato
umbrella if you will he's built
relationships in the middle east
that nobody ever thought was possible i
mean think about
arab countries who are willing to do a
peace deal
with israel impossible not so
and so what what i hope is that this
administration is going to follow
through on a number of those things
that president trump did very very well
and i'm very concerned because a lot of
their top advisors
blinken sullivan those are the guys that
negotiated the so-called joint
plan of action dealing the so-called
iran deal
and of course america gave up billions
of dollars in hard cash and then
added to it uh billions more that
allowed the ch
it allowed the the heavily heavy weight
of what they were doing in terms of
their economy it allowed that
heavyweight to be taken off because
communist china is now
the number one purchaser of their oil
we've got to make sure that the
europeans follow through
on where they started out with president
trump whether you like trump or not
the fact is the things he did were
remarkable in terms of protecting the
american people
it extended domestically to protecting
our border
countries without borders aren't
countries okay so
the free flow of individuals across
borders is not something that gives you
sovereignty over your territory and on
top of that he rebuilt america's
defenses
he got us out of an endless war in
afghanistan got us out of an endless war
in iraq
pulled troops back from places where
they'd been for in some cases decades
the bottom line of it was all done to
protect the american people
and like i say deterrence is the number
one objective of a strong military
israel knows that
we know that does anybody else in this
administration know it besides you and
me i hope so
so the reason why i'm asking this is
because you know everything in life you
can learn
if i know who your enemies are i know
where i align with you
right if i know who your allies are i
know how i align with you
and you've heard the sayings an enemy of
an enemy is a friend a friend of an
enemy is an enemy
you've this is not the first time i'm
you're hearing this so
who would you say when trump was
president for the four years versus now
biden being president for the last you
know whatever timeline is that he's been
a president
who would you say were trump's biggest
enemies who constantly got on his way
in his way and who do you think are
biden's biggest enemies today
and who they who could be their biggest
enemies so trump's biggest enemies
biden's biggest enemies and i'm not
talking about just china or iran i'm
talking about media universe i'm talking
about like social i'm talking a little
bit deeper than
who would you say are trump's biggest
enemies versus biden's biggest enemies
well i i i want to just
go on the record saying president donald
trump was a friend
okay he was a friend before he was
president uh we have these great
ceremonies
of the army navy game back before kovit
right after he was elected he attended
the army navy game with my foundation
freedom alliance
right half the game on the army side of
the field half the game on the navy side
of the field with our with our
supporters and friends and our board
members and the like i told him then
don't be an enemy to yourself
unfortunately he never took that advice
he
would call me up at various times both
before he was president and afterwards
and he'd ask for it for advice i would
end it
always with give me your phone because
you
are your own worst enemy biden doesn't
have that problem
by biden it's not because biden is more
humble
and he and he probably is i mean there's
not a lot of humility in donald trump
i mean the the trial that's going on
right as you and i are speaking right
now
in the united states senate is proof of
that i mean the bottom line of it is
he became his own worst enemy in the
things that he would say in the way he
would say them
the things he did needed to be done they
needed to be done back during the
so-called obama biden administration
they weren't they were being done by
donald trump
which improved look it one of one of the
most important things
that donald trump did for america was he
created
tens of millions of jobs not just a
million
but literally over 10 million jobs he
gave people the dignity of
work there were people many of the
minorities perhaps even most
who'd never had a job before and they
could proudly walk home
in many cases to the woman that they'd
made pregnant in or out of marriage
and he would hold up the check and say
i've got a job
okay very very important to the people
who supported him
very important obviously to the economy
of the united states
i mean the fastest recovery we've ever
had from a serious recession
it wasn't because of what obama and
biden had been doing in their eight
years
it was because donald trump came in and
knew how to work the system
and made it work so that other people
could find work
and get to work go to work bring home a
paycheck
the pandemic got in the way of all of
that the challenge that
presidents both trump and biden are
going to have
ultimately is what happens as a
consequence of this
coronavirus what what is going to be the
ultimate outcome of it
because if this vaccine isn't working
and the israelis are a perfect example
of apparently they've figured it out
they've got one across the board
apparently lord knows there's a lot of
bologna about
vaccines and and my lovely wife and i
have already had our first shot we're
going to get our second shot here
on friday and so we're looking forward
to that
we got 18 grandkids okay many of them
are sitting right now around our kitchen
table doing their homework because they
haven't been in school in a year
and and i'm hoping someday i can use my
internet at home because
literally they've all got their laptops
open in the kitchen table doing
everything from math to science to
history to your house is very peaceful
right now very quiet
i can already hear it i'm in my office
is because
they tied up back in my office
okay so so you said trump's biggest
enemy
was himself give me your phone put the
phone down you know you you you're your
biggest enemy
turn up alexander great years ago said i
haven't met the enemy it is i
trump has his own enemy fair enough
let's look at biden
who's who's who's going to be biden's
biggest enemy because i don't know if he
has an enemy right now who's biden's
biggest enemy today well i i'm not sure
that
enemy is the right one look i'm a
conservative you're a conservative i
mean you're an entrepreneur i'm an
entrepreneur we've created jobs for
other people
okay so i understand that i don't know
that he necessarily has done so i mean
i'm looking at some of the things that
he's announced in his executive orders
and and he talks like he's going to
unify the country
but we now have something that's never
happened before in american history
probably is unconstitutional and that
they're trying a person who's
no longer in office in an impeachment
process that says
the only punishment for impeachment is
removal from office
and if they want they can then say you
can never have another office never
another elected office
there's nothing in our constitution that
says you can impeach someone
who's an american citizen it's all about
office holders it doesn't have to be
just the president could be a federal
judge
it could be all kinds of people you can
impeach senators you can beach
congressmen but no one's ever impeached
somebody who's
already out of office and certainly no
one's ever tried
that person which is what's happening
right now no so
is one of biden's problems is going to
be trying to unify the country
that no matter what he says about it
patrick he is continuing to divide
america
and i i tell people i said you know
particularly my grandkids i mean i
our our age span is sophomore in college
uh down to you know just barely stopped
crawling here a few weeks ago
yeah all walking around okay okay you
got a 19-year age span between the
oldest and the youngest 18 of them
18 of them yeah and and thankfully
they're all here in virginia and they
all
they they congregate in granddads and
grandmas that's that's nice
oh it's a great blessing there's no
doubt about it so i look at what
our our grandkids are facing our
grandkids are facing a mountain of debt
uncertainty about covid and the idea
that they will never be able to dig out
from under it and i don't i don't see
anything that's being done by this
administration
that isn't going to be even more
disheartening to their future
i mean the mountain of debt we've
accumulated as a consequence of coving
the closures that have happened all
across america as a consequence of it
you know in in virginia where i am you
could only have a certain number of
people go to church
but you can go to any bar in the in the
state and pack the thing without masks
when you look at that i say you know
this isn't just a political battle
and what's going on in america isn't a
contest between red and blue
it's a theological battle and that is
the the spirit of america was developed
by our founders and
the framers of our constitution as a
judeo-christian value system based on
the holy bible i got one right here on
my desk
i look at that and i say we most of our
culture seems to have walked away from
that
so i'm what i'm saying is to our
grandkids what needs to happen
is there has to be a spiritual renewal
to unify america
you're not going to do it politically
certainly not with what's going on in
washington dc right now
and so the reality of it is my i want to
i want to be a role model to those 18
grandkids
i want to you know there's this
wonderful passage in paul's second
letter to timothy
and it's probably his last letter he's a
he's a prisoner in rome
he's about to be executed by nero he
writes to timothy who is a
bishop in what is today turkey ephesus
and he's encouraging him to stay on the
job and at one point in that lengthy
letter
probably written by luke and signed by
paul
he writes about i want you to i'm
paraphrasing ii timothy i want you to
remember that i
am the person who showed you how to
fight the good fight how to finish the
race
and how to keep the faith right
we need people like that who will unify
america
i'm not pretending to be that for the
rest of the country i want to be that
for those 18 grandkids
and of all the things i've done in life
the most important you know and i've had
a
a real adventure there are very few
people you've ever had on i've watched a
bunch of your podcasts brother
there's very few people who had a life
as exciting as mine
to include the excitement of falling
down the stairs while i was
shoveling off the deck sunday afternoon
right
in the second what i call the biden
blizzards you know where was dave when
that happened was dave they're helping
you out or we couldn't find them
well actually actually one of our sons
said to me afterwards is dad
all the things you've done in life
they're gonna find your body at the
bottom of the deck having
bumped himself down the stairs and
instead of a rifle in your hand
you're going to have a shovel and
everybody's going to say what a dumb sob
he wants to have gone out in the middle
of a snowstorm and clear the ice off the
deck
i i look at i look at those 18 grandkids
and i want to do the kinds of things
patrick
and then whatever days that the good
lord's going to give me left
that encourage them to fight the good
fight finish the race
and and basically go out there and do
good things
because you know the example is what we
all need as we're coming up to look at
somebody and say you know what i aspire
to one day
you know and it's good that those 18
grandkids have a grandfather like yeah
i'm sure you got a lot of
i'm sure you're the grandfather every
grandkid would want to sit there and
just hear stories can you tell me
another story can you because i bet
you've got thousands of stories
but you know the reason why i'm asking
these questions about
uh trump and biden is when when biden
first started campaigning right
i'll never forget he went on instagram
and an instagram account
i think i was the first person to
comment on instagram when he
created his first post and i said it's
official biden's going to be announcing
that he's running i think 60 days later
he announced he's running and boom
he ran so then he goes in he's kind of
watching everybody you know it's ham and
sanders it's all these other guys pete
you know
the kamala the first one him and kamala
went at it then slowly but
surely sanders came out this person came
out that person came out and it's him so
it went from aoc and sanders camp
elizabeth warren's camp you know
kamala's camp to now let's let's make a
decision
it's going to be then when the debate
started we thought he was going to
protect a lot of aoc and bernie's
philosophy socialism you know let's go
out there and you know you know
80 trillion dollars 30 trillion dollars
over 10 years for you know climate
change
and then he became president when he
became president
he didn't put aoc on the administration
he didn't go out there and put a lot of
these guys on the team
he went pretty moderate let's just say
moderate he's
still left but not as left as we thought
he was going to be
came out with executive orders i think
the second highest executive order since
uh
fdr fdr to 20 38 32 in his first 30 days
and i think he's down 28th
and i think obama's third right after
that so then we have him today you don't
see him a lot on tv
you saw trump on tv every day you don't
see him on twitter quiet you don't even
know if he exits no one knows what he
could be golfing right now we have no
he could be playing video games right
now fortnite we don't know what he's
doing right now right we have no idea
what he's doing right now
then he becomes the president and now we
have the new
you know everything that's coming out do
you think he's going to be the president
that will be
quiet we won't hear a lot from him could
be
he'll be a little bit center left he'll
do some of the stuff that he needs to do
to protect the left but not
far left and he'll stay committed to his
views and he'll be controlled by wall
street that's going to impose certain
things uh we need you to do this we need
you to do this we need to do that
but there's not going to be any major
changes taking place for you
or do you think he's just getting warmed
up be patient
there's going to be dramatic changes
taking place between now and midterms
well i think there are dramatic changes
taking place i mean basically he's put
israel on notice
and of course you now have the issue of
what's happening to bibi netanyahu
and you've got the communist chinese
helping the iranians
stir up a horn in its nest they've
already issued the kinds of orders
to our military that quite frankly i
don't see them
helpful i mean his executive order is
saying that the military's got to
help transexuals that does nothing for
military readiness they're
non-deployable
i mean there's there's no way that
that's a positive sign for our military
they've already looked at the the
weapons exchanges we've got with saudi
arabia
with taiwan in other words what we've
been doing is trying to build
relationships with allies who can help
us carry out our foreign policy
he said the other day that diplomacy is
now the center of our foreign policy
this is a speech that he made
at the state department oh contraire mr
president
the fact is diplomacy is not the center
of our foreign policy
u.s interests are the center of american
foreign policy diplomacy is simply a
tool
by which you get what is best for our
country i mean
and so i i i don't i don't necessarily
agree with you patrick that he's going
to be
just a center left kind of guy i look at
those kinds of things that are happening
today and the effect it's having on our
allies the effect that it's going to
have on our adversaries
and saying this is not helpful
domestically
the idea that we're going to solve the
problem of covid
right with nothing more than wearing a
mask and oh by the way you know
airlines have got to make sure that
everybody gets on an airplane gets
tested
that you're talking years away
i mean the idea of of delays in i'm
looking out into the
the beautiful mountains of virginia
right here but i'm looking at
empty parking lots in the middle of the
day the the highways are empty coming to
work
and i i live 75 miles west of washington
okay when i get on the road nowadays and
there's very little traffic still
right and the idea that we can have this
many people out of work
and they're now going to pass additional
funding that it's going to give
everybody what 1400
in the 5 1400 in their pocket to me
that's not the answer the answer is
getting people vaccinated so that we're
not going to be hit with this plague
for psalm 101 in in the old testament
what
what nice jewish friends of mine call
the torah psalm 101
look at what is written there about
pestilence
plagues and enemies and and that's why i
say that
most of what we need today is a
spiritual reawakening in this
in this country it doesn't have to be a
particular denomination
but you can't alienate christianity in
this country by doing many of the things
that they're doing
i mean socially the idea of saying the
taxpayers of the united states are now
going to pay because of these executive
orders
the people of america are now going to
pay for abortions worldwide
and planned parenthood's going to be
able to carry him out in the united
states
donald trump stopped that much to the
acclaim of
probably being the best most pro-life
president we've ever
had and unfortunately all that's being
changed so
culturally spiritually politically
economically and national security wise
i don't see biden as being particularly
helpful to what we need to be as a
nation well you're saying far left i
mean far left to me is raising taxes you
know
uh uh and getting rid of all the tax
cuts that we had the last four years far
left for me would be
you know if we go out there with the 30
trillion dollars budget over the next
10 years for climate change far left
would be let's eliminate all of college
debt to 1.5 trillion dollars which is
what elizabeth warren proposed
far left to me is ubi let's give a
thousand dollar income for every
american the whole andrew yang
so that's why i mean i see far left
because i've lived in far left so
far left then you have left so
far left to me is socialism communism do
you think he's going to go that far
well certainly if we did the things that
the vice president of the united states
wants
done and he does it legislatively
because you know
we've lost the senate the conservatives
lost the senate
she now makes it she's already done it
twice now
and she's probably going to do it again
here in his hearings that are ongoing
right now
and and they're going to continue this
farce that's happening in washington dc
i don't see any of that that's unifying
to this country or good for the future
again i
come back to those 18 grandkids yep
right i mean
i the middle school ones okay
when i get home at night they say that
granddad what is this about an
impeachment
they've got the constitution they're
supposed to be looking at and
i don't see any provision for that in
this constitution right here granddad
how can we be doing it i said because
the far left is in charge of washington
dc
i mean patrick if you think about it
the constitution has guided nearly every
president
and through this the most difficult
times we've ever had as a nation a civil
war
right and so people say is this the
worst of times heck no
america survived far worse than this you
know 670
000 americans died in that civil war and
the population wasn't a third of what it
is today
so i my concern patrick is that too many
people are taking
up it's okay it's going to be all right
well spiritually i'm kind of there with
you
i think the future looks bright and i
don't see him being
the far left because i don't see biden
as a true believer i see sanders as a
true believer
meaning sanders becomes president you're
not going to be able to control him he's
going to do what he's going to do
because he could care less he's been a
true believer since he got married in
russia
i don't see biden as a true believer i
see biden as a
jfk coming from there maybe he's moved a
little bit more to the left because
that's what the times have changed
and by the way this is not an
endorsement this this is not a
an endorsement i've given i'm just
saying the concerns because now that
it's validated
i understand during the 18 months of
campaign if biden gets elected
it's going to be this it's going to be
that but now that we're here
and everybody wants to try to figure out
how to pivot and make the adjustments is
it the end of the world
i think i'm kind of with you i don't
think it's the end of the world i would
point out to you
that if kamala harris becomes the
president united states i agree all
right
it's the goose is pretty well cooked at
that point
okay i agree there i agree there so 2024
do you think 2024 biden will still run
or will
will the face be kamala what do you
think is going to happen 2020 look
i think enough people are already
finding out how
what's the right word i don't think the
guy's got you know alzheimer's or
anything but
i think he's a feeble man i don't see
him as a leader
i mean if you wanted to be a great
leader
right you get elected president united
states
the speaker of the house who is a crazy
leftist stands up and says we're going
to impeach the guy you just beat
and at that point a real leader says i
really want to be the unifier of america
picks up the phone and says miss pelosi
stop it stop it before you vote on it
because it's not first of all he's not
going to get convicted
and all he's going to do is make it more
difficult to unify the country but he's
not really a unifier
you see he's quite frankly he's not much
at all i agree with you he's not
the far crazy leftist that kamal harris
is but the bottom line of it is
god forbid something happens to the guy
i mean he's older than i am and i'm a
pretty old guy
and so i i don't think he's going to be
shoveling off the deck over
in massachusetts afternoon where he
lived where he once lived or the white
house but the bottom line of it is
something happens to him she she
convinces people to invoke the 25th
amendment which a lot of people were
trying to get you know vice president
pence to do
he had the wisdom not to do that he had
the wisdom to make sure that
that there was a transition and that the
letter he wrote
uh and i was just looking at it before
we went on there and i couldn't find the
darn thing
the letter he wrote about why he did not
do what others were urging him to do and
others included president trump
was the constitution of the united
states it's a beautifully written piece
it ought to have been on the front page
of every newspaper in america and it
wasn't
and unfortunately it's not my front in
front of me because i read it on the
record right
right here with you patrick because it's
it's right spiritually
it's right economically it's right
politically and it's a constitutional
answer
to why he didn't invoke the 25th
amendment or try to get the
all of what was going on in washington
turned upside down
and unfortunately unfortunately what
happens on the 6th
just takes all the accomplishments of
that administration
and there are many and this basically
buries them underneath
that riot that occurred up on cap i
agree i
agree with that uh uh there's something
very
i don't know what it is like there's
something very peaceful
about mike pence i don't know how to
describe it you just
i'm sure you saw the debate between him
and kamala here it's like the way he
gave her respect
but he addressed the concern yeah so
tell us what are you going to be doing
with the court packing is it fair to say
that you're not going yeah we're going
to be court packing
you know we're not you know not she
didn't say that she said how about all
the
unfair the fact that we don't have a
single you know african and so
she took that was okay so you are
planning on court packing and
some of the stuff you talk i like the
way he approaches it do you think he's
the leading candidate for 2024 for
republicans
i do okay i've known him a long time i
know a lot of the people very close to
him
uh he has a son who's united states
marine
and who i talked to before he decided to
do so
and uh i think what vice president trump
vice president pence offers is the kind
of leadership that the republican party
desperately needs right now and quite
frankly the nation needs i mean
he's a spiritually devoted individual he
knows his lord and savior jesus christ
he's unashamed to say so
he's the kind of person who is a uniter
he's done so with the republican party
before because
when he was in the congress he actually
bought brought together the conference
of republicans and republicans have
always been kind of
throwing their elbows out and getting in
the way of each other and he brought
them together as
the head of the republican conference in
that congress in the house of
representatives
he became a great governor of indiana he
brought people into the republican party
who had never been there before
and president trump to his credit did
people the same thing
now the guy who can do that probably
best is new
i think his title now is visiting fellow
at the heritage foundation
and he's going to be hopefully your
guest in mind on our podcast
we had the president of a heritage uh uh
university here whom we had a wonderful
conversation yeah i mean
it's just a fabulous conversation with
and i got more messages from
his wisdom that he had all my my kids
are going through some of his courses
and they're
nine and five years nine and seven years
old they're taking courses but uh
so so going back to that so if mike
pence is the lead for republicans
you know who would you put second third
do you think
trump has a chance of running again in
2024 the best thing is for
him to just sit this one out and say
look you've done your part your one-term
president
let somebody else come in what do you
think is going to happen with trump
well i'm not jewish so i don't have the
gift of prophecy
so but look at my sense is
that the damage that was done on the
sixth and and the damage that's being
done right now
on on capitol hill in the in the united
states senate
and the damage that they've got they're
going to try to destroy this man
okay they're going to bring lawsuits
against every one of his hotels
all of his golf courses there's going to
be an inquisition the likes of which
none of us can imagine i've been through
a little bit of that back in the 80s
there's going to be senate
investigations there's going to be house
investigations there's going to be
criminal charges brought by probably a
dozen or more
u.s attorneys what it's going to do is
try to they're going to try to ruin him
right and so given that reality and
given the fact that he's got a bunch of
kids of his own
and a bunch of grandkids he would be
wise i think to focus
on that to encourage others to get into
involved in it i don't think you got to
give up
a leadership role but i think what needs
to happen right now is he needs to
protect himself and his family he needs
around i hate to say this
and don't tell anybody i have a son
who's a lawyer so
don't put that out there but he needs
some really good lawyers around him and
he's not had a bunch of them yet
yeah i mean it's it's uh i mean if
you're saying not a bunch of them you're
putting giuliani that's not a good
lawyer
if you're saying that but i i don't
think that's what you're saying
was a great mayor wow okay fair i mean
if that's what you that's a pretty
direct uh call out right there but
do you do you think mike pence will be
able to unite
the lincoln project folks which is the
mccains and the bushes
and the mega crowd you think mike could
bring those two together and get some of
the independence on the side
i think so i mean i i trust his i i
trust his instincts
on top of it i mean he's got a great
career as a as a congressman
as a as a radio talk going to do a
podcast now just like you and i do
he's going to make sure that the kind of
folks that he puts around him reinforce
his spiritual nature
his economic ideas his national security
ideas protecting american sovereignty
all those kinds of things that really
ultimately are important to the american
people
and i think he's got a couple of years
to make all that happen i mean i
quite frankly in looking at the at the
makeup of the us house of
representatives
and the numbers of republican senators
who are now retiring
i think it's much more likely we take
back the house of representatives
in two years than it is we take back the
senate
interesting to say that really
now you got to understand patrick if i
knew so much about politics
you and i would be having this
conversation from my u.s senate office
last time i checked i'm not there
fair enough fair enough so okay i have
two other topics and a bonus question
about a movie that i'm curious to know
what your answer is going to be with
this let's let's touch on the next topic
negotiating with china and iran you've
dealt with iran before obviously iran
contrary back in the 80s you kind of
alluded to it a minute
ago but what is the right approach to
negotiate with the china or to negotiate
within iran i'm curious to know your
answer on those too
i i look at the the proper words would
be something like what ronald reagan
used to be trust but verify okay
the the power the joint cooperation
so-called deal with iran was a terrible
piece of
legislation not a it's a terrible
diplomatic effort
okay you can't go back to that you've
got to make sure that you can address
the things
and hold them accountable i mean
accountability is the whole name of the
nature
of what you do how do you how do you
verify with them and hold them
accountable how would you do that
keep the sanctions on in other words go
to your allies and we've got a bunch of
them
no matter what other people want to say
about them but the europeans have got to
backstop us on holding the sanctions in
place
because the sanctions are hurting the
ayatollahs and the sanctions can make
them work
and the people look at it and say why do
we have this terrible theocracy
running our judicial system our
government our economy
and the islamic revolutionary guard
corps spewing terrorism around the world
and they literally have the ability to
do that so make sure that they're held
accountable
number two china is the same thing if
you look at what china is doing
in all kinds of the economy national
security
international affairs space all of it
stealing the intellectual property of
the american people
is not the way to get it done if they
want to compete fairly in the world
stage fine
we're the ones that let them in remember
the biden the so-called
obama biden administration the ones that
let them in the wto
okay the obama biden administration
believed what they were telling him
about various other communicable
diseases
back through organizations at the united
nations
that the communist chinese dominate i'm
talking about world health organization
right
i mean we just had a w.h.o spokesman was
it yesterday day before yesterday stand
up and say
we've looked around we now know this
disease did not come out of a laboratory
in wuhan province
we do know that i mean i don't know
don't get me wrong i don't pretend that
i would know
how it got spread how it was created but
i do know how it got spread
because they shut down all kinds of
internal movement inside communist china
and they allowed people to go overseas
where's the first big european
outbreak it's in northern italy why
because the communist chinese
bought out lamborghini all ferrari
all of those big attack and clothing
makers and handbag makers and shoemakers
that's and the label on the thing still
says made
in italy right you look at a ferrari
this is made in
but who made it in italy hundreds of
thousands of communist chinese
experts went over there took over the
businesses and of course the italians
made money on it
they were glad to have it and of course
the product is still made in italy
but the people who were coming back and
forth weekly
out of wuhan province spread the disney
first to italy and
now across the rest of the world same
thing of all these other places
you know look at brazil look at panama
look at as i say sub-saharan africa
i i i know i'm not a doctor i don't
pretend to be
but you know what there's a reason why
people who take
uh hydroxychloroquine from malaria
aren't getting the disease
as rapidly as we are here why is that
because they take hydroxychloroquine now
i'm not telling people to stop
you know i'm not telling people they
ought not to get a vaccination
betsy and i got ours we're going for a
final one on friday the bottom line of
it is
there's reasons why places where malaria
has been
dominant don't get the disease at the
same rate we do because and
their medical infrastructure is a
fraction of what we have
so i look at those kinds of things i
said there's got to be a way that we can
hold communist china accountable
and and hunter biden cannot be the
architect of our policy
toward china do you think the sanctions
on china and iran are going to stay put
or you think
biden's going to lift them i think he's
already in the process of lifting it
he's talking to other people about it
he's talking to them about it
i mean if you do that the idea of a
revolution or even a
guard was in iran when the revolution
took place on command from shadow
romania
and there's a formula for it you know
carter pretty much
choked the shah until it was too late
yeah we're coming we'll support you
we'll support you we'll support you
sorry we can't support you what i mean
you can't support me hey i think it's
best you leave what do you mean that's
best
it's my country so it was a very
interesting strategy
that they used back then with carter i
mean we're very close to getting there
with iran but uh
if they lift the sanctions we may be
waiting another
uh 10 to 20 years to see another
pressure type situation like now right
like we have right now in iran where
there is a possibility of regime change
so if those things are lifted i don't
think that's changing anytime soon so
next next topic here since you were the
president of nra
last month january to january gun sales
is up 80
2 million plus sales of firearms last
month is the third biggest month ever
last year in 2020 i think we're up 64
from the year prior to that the numbers
are just staggering what's going on
right now
why why are so many americans buying 80
more guns in january compared to last
january
why now what what what are they thinking
about i'm curious what you'll say about
that well
you know first of all you had a
president last january
named donald trump who is a big
supporter of the second amendment
okay number two you now have a president
who's not a big supporter of the second
amendment
and people are very concerned about
being able to protect their families
look we saw we saw uh the summer of riot
right with organizations that are now
quote
i don't know how they're going to do
this but these are organizations blm
intifada boogaloo uh
q anon who are rioting all over major
cities portland seattle
milwaukee la washington dc
burning destroying and people looked at
it and said
i don't have a way of protecting my
family and they went out and bought
firearms
okay and they can still do that today
except things are about to get a whole
lot worse here in
the state of virginia because we got a
crazy governor who has literally
forgiven me for putting it this way but
this is the truth he is
a a baby killing gun grabbing
race-baiter who is going to come after
the guns
okay let me just a quick story without
confessing to any crimes
i've already been there once never again
when our kids when our grandkids we had
11 grandsons and seven granddaughters
when when they turned 14 i'm allowed to
give a president
a present to their birthday and it's a
box and it's a long box
and inside the on the front of the box
it says
if you learn to use everything in this
box you'll never go hungry you'll never
be lost and you need fear nothing
and i will show you how and they open
the box up and the first thing they see
isn't a firearm they know there's one in
the box because they can feel the weight
of it
and they've seen it happen with their
older siblings cousins
and the first thing they pick up is the
holy bible i said it just happens that
half the months a year have 31 proverbs
in it
right and you know there's 31 proverbs
and i want you to go and the very first
thing about using this present is i want
you to do
one a day and come back and give me a
book report 31 days from now
right and they do and the second thing
is a map and a compass
and i i used to teach land navigation to
marines right
and and they there's there's just like
you've got in a marine
you know training command you've got
engineer stakes and a a metal box welded
to it
out in the woods at terrain features and
i show them how to use that map sheet
to 125 000 scale and that compass how to
navigate
and of course the third thing is and
after i've teaching that i said
then i'm going to let you have this
shotgun it's going to be engraved on the
side that this is a gift from granddad
not my name
just granddad okay and it's your name on
it and it's your birthday
and i will take you out and i will show
you how to take it apart and put it back
together blindfolded
then i'll show you how to clean it and
then i'll show you how to shoot it
so that at the end of the day you're not
going to waste it as a shotgun
you're not going to waste it missing
birds and i can i have a wonderful
experience doing that kind of thing
there's lots of people who are going to
find that to be unlawful because
a 14 year old is now supposed to get a
background check
what the hell's a background check on a
14 year old kid to look like
and the only wrinkle in that fabric was
after one of the girls watched her older
brother get
a shotgun she asked granddad where's
mine
so i got to go out and buy another
shotgun if i give that shotgun tour am i
breaking the law in virginia i don't
know yet
that's why people are pressed now to get
a firearm that's why concealed carry
permits are out
just off the charts and and and that's a
good reason
that americans are still able to protect
their families against the uncertainty
of somebody showing up on your back
porch trying to knock your door down
and they're not the law they're
criminals and so
given that given the temperature of the
times i think it's appropriate
what's unfortunate is the fact that
virginia is a big military state like
what
do you what are you doing touching
virginia
the history the rich history of virginia
like i understand
some other states but virginia's decked
out with the
military so um you gave me a great
opportunity this is a book about a
virginian who in 1775
got a note from george washington who's
up in cambridge people forget
the youngsters don't get history unless
they live with granddad
and the the rifleman is a fellow by the
name of daniel morgan
and he writes to morgan who he come to
know during the french and indian war
and he says come to come to cambridge
with 100 virginia rifles
which means the guys to carry him and so
he does
it takes him 21 days to walk from
winchester virginia
literally right down the street from
where we live just on the other side of
the shenandoah river
and it were 21 days if you do it on the
highway
it's about a 480 mile walk but you know
i-95 wasn't there there were no bridges
there were ferry boats across the rivers
there's some places where you could ford
the rivers and it's so
600 miles in round numbers he arrives 21
days
i tell the boy scouts this story and i
said let's go for a hike
just imagine trying to walk 25 or 30
miles a day
in the middle of a forest in the middle
of you know literally the middle of
summer
and he arrives up in boston the autumn
is just beginning and the first thing
that happens is
congress congress and their infinite
wisdom orders washington
to attack of course they arrive at
literally the walls around quebec on new
year's eve
and the next day the enlistments expire
and they've been defeated
that's book one about daniel morgan book
two coming out this summer
wow thank you for giving me the chance
to promote it that is amazing last
question for you before we wrap up you
ever seen a movie a few good men with
jack
nicholson oh sure okay so you know the
last part where you know
tom cruise goes up and you tell me the
truth you can't hand you want another
tell me you can't handle the training
right code red and the whole thing they
go back and forth you know
i'm going to try to ask this question
the way for it to make sense to you so
you know guys campaign i will not raise
taxes
they become president they raise taxes
okay you will be able to keep your
insurance power you know
that you can okay so that's a lot let's
just
qualify that as a light let's set that
part aside but then the other part of it
is
behind closed doors you're you're
negotiating you're doing some stuff that
it's not black and white there's a
there's gray area in it you know and
military to develop to go through war
people's lives on the line you know
i interviewed a sniper yesterday 33
confirms in 100 days in afghanistan
it's a different one like you can't
explain it you know some of the stories
hey let me tell you what happened over
here right do you think there's an
element of things that happen behind
closed doors with presidents with
military with
war with negotiation that
the the day-to-day person couldn't
handle the truth
if we really knew what was really taking
place i don't know if that question
makes sense or not you know what look
i i think to the extent this is possible
you can't do this if you're building
a weapon system or an intelligence
collection system
but you can do it with almost everything
else if there's not a national security
component that needs to be kept secret
there ought to be transparency i mean
look at a husband cannot get along with
a wife and boy or vice versa
if they're not transparent with one
another ultimately it all comes apart
right and we've seen that happen to
friends of ours and you have to look at
the idea of transparency is valid
there needs to be more of that in
washington there needs to be more
cooperation
there needs to be unifying but none of
that's happening with this
administration that's why
i take part uh i'm not not trying to
disagree with you completely
but i think but biden is a failed leader
already
and i think he's doing things behind the
scenes ultimately they're gonna
require legislation and hopefully
there'll be enough republicans left
together
hang together literally as ben franklin
said we'll either hang together or hang
separately
the fact is the republican party has got
to get their act together
i still believe that the right guy to do
that is mike pence
i still believe that the american people
want capitalism
you and i are capitalists we're
entrepreneurs you want that kind of
opportunity i want it
most of all for my grandkids right
because i've they are the next
generation of people who are going to
inherit whatever mess we leave them
and the idea of leaving them in
trillions and trillions of dollars of
debt
that they're never going to be able to
pay off and then to promise oh by the
way
we'll go the government's going to take
care of your college loans
i the the idea that that the government
can do everything
is a foreign idea to the framers of our
constitution
the constitution was created to protect
us we the people
that's the first three words of that
constitution right hundreds of times
i've raised my right hand to administer
that oath
and we've commit to defend against all
enemies foreign and domestic
the constitution of the united states
and i look at that and it
it the oath ends with so help me god
if you go to my website you can see one
of those oaths being given to those guys
and and they're all shouting out
together we've got to return to the
spiritual roots of this country
that's what gives me hope that's what
gives me assurance that things are going
to turn out better than they sometimes
look today
probably better here we're supposed to
get between seven and nine inches of
snow tomorrow
and over the course the next four days
and another one of these biden blizzards
that have just come down and shut
everything down
and lord willing that won't happen to
our country well sir thank you so much
for your time i have
really really enjoyed having you on by
team and as a guest thank you
i have too and i appreciate it i enjoy
the way i always do
semper fidelis that's the motto of the
united states marine corps but it's more
than a slogan
it's a way of life always faithful thank
you frank
thank you what a story right from a man
that's got experience personally with
iran with you know
politics with challenges in the past to
give perspective
and color on what's taking place today
i'm curious to know what you took away
from it comment below
also if you enjoyed this interview i
think you'll also enjoy my sit down with
larry
arne who is the president of heritage
university if you've never seen that
click over here to watch that interview
take care everybody bye-bye